are reports from Portugal the police
looking for Madeleine McCann are to
begin searching a dam in Portugal which
is 50 kilometers from where she went
missing back in 2007. German officers
will be joined by a team from Portugal
and offices from the UK while the
British three-year-old went missing
while on holiday and prior to luge 16
years ago let's get more from ashnahonag
in The Newsroom actually this is just
developing this story but but what do we
know about why this search is
potentially going to happen we have been
hearing this from our colleagues in
Portugal at Jane we understand that this
search will take place tomorrow and it's
going to focus on a dam as you say some
50 kilometers away from prior to luge in
The Algarve it is our understanding
there in Portugal that tomorrow they
will begin what is due to be a two-day
search at the request of German police
and the team specifically investigating
The Disappearance of Madeleine McCann
this is the garage Dam it is a place
though that was frequented by the main
suspect in this case Christian B we know
Christian B is a currently convicted
child abuser and a drug dealer he's
currently in prison at serving a
sentence there for raping a seven to
two-year-old woman in the same area of
the Algarve region of Portugal from
where Madeleine McCann went missing as
you say 16 years ago this will be the
first major search in this investigation
since about 2014 it's our understanding
that detectives from Scotland Yard will
also also be present but at this stage
their involvement is is simply a
watching brief and it will be focused
primarily on the Portuguese police but
also the German authorities who'll be
searching this Dam from the looks of
things it looks like a incredibly huge
Reservoir it's going to take it's going
to be a lot of ground for them to cover
it's worth saying that Christian B was
made the official suspect last year but
he has always denied his involvement in
Madeleine McCann's disappearance but
that search of that remote Reservoir
will start tomorrow and will continue
for the next two days